James Harden trade as we send it down to
Patrick O'Neal okay Brian thanks very
much for those Clipper fans that are
still here if you can hear me let's get
some love and appreciation for James
hard James you get the ball tied at 100
and you hit a big shot a four-point play
What's going through your mind there get
a shot up that's something I work on
every single day so uh get a shot up my
step back and and I have confidence in
it which I I work on it every day like I
said so uh it feel good it feel good to
finally get a victory uh now we got to
get this thing going oh they hear you
now okay there it is there's the love
and appreciation what does it mean for
you to finally get that win as a clipp
uh it's a it's it's a sign of relief you
know it's it's been some tough times
these last few games but uh we got a
bigger pitcher uh and trying to be the
last team standing so there going to be
a process and if you guys stick with us
uh be some great results at the end of
the season love to hear it James in that
fourth quarter some big defensive plays
by zubot and the entire team for you
guys to close out a game late what does
that mean uh it's a stepping stone for
us you know what I mean now so now we
got to watch film practice and get ready
for a good road trip so uh first win to
mini your owner stopped by Steve Balmer
what did he tell you uh first win as a
Clipper uh it's exciting all right there
it is got to keep that inhouse Brian
back to you Patrick thank you so much
Clippers are
winners